Good morning, John!
Trilobites are super weird, and I want you to know more about them.
It's easy to forget that the moment we live in is just this
one snapshot of this huge history of life on Earth.
And yeah, we have to, and should, and do study now...
But also, there's a lot to learn if we look at the past
and it can just be fascinating, as well.
Which is why we've teamed up with PBS Digital Studios
to make a new show.
It's called EONS and it's about the entire history of life on Earth
So like most biology, as what's happening right now, EONS is everything else.
All of the life that has happened so far until now.
Turns out, there's lots of good stuff to cover here.
Our first episode is about trilobites, of course.
The emergence of trilobites happened around 500 million-ish years ago.
It was part of what's called the Cambrian Explosion,
where life on Earth got way more complex.
They were the first true arthropods.
Arthropods now take up three-quarters of the world's
species, so basically, good on you, trilobites!
Arthropods, basically, are the segmented exoskeleton-
covered things that you see all around you right now.
Spiders, butterflies, millipedes, crabs,
like those things, too.
Even though horseshoe crabs share some family resemblance with trilobites
and some horseshoe crab species did coexist with
trilobites, they are old horseshoe crabs.
The last species of trilobites went extinct
around 250 million years ago.
But even though they did not last forever,
they were extremely successful!
They existed for 270 million years.
Primates, for comparison, have existed
for around 50 million years.
So, we have a lot of catching up to do.
We found trilobite fossils on every continent
and described over 15,000 species.
One of the weird reasons why trilobites are so well
studied and why we find so many of them,
is that most trilobite fossils aren't actually trilobites.
It's nice being an organism whose skin grows with them,
but that is not the case for arthropods.
If the arthropod wants to grow,
it has to shed its exoskeleton
and then move out of that old house that was too small for it.
And when it does that it leaves behind that shed
exoskeleton, which can then fossilize.
and that happened a lot, obviously, with trilobites.
So the majority of Trilobite fossils aren't the organism
that died. They're the shed exoskeleton
which, of course, we can still use to date the trilobite,
and to figure out what kind it was and learn more about the species.
There are a bunch of reasons trilobite
were probably so successful.
Their strong exoskeletons, their jointed legs.
But they also - this is a pretty big deal -
had the first complex eyes.
And trilobite eyes are freakin' awesome!
Some of them have thousands of individual lenses
and the lenses are made of calcite.
They're a crystal.
The trilobite grew crystals in its eyes!
Our eye lenses, they can flex and change size,
so if I look at something close-up,
I focus on it and then I look at something far away,
I focus on that,
The lenses in my eyes are actually changing shape.
If your lens is made of rock, that's hard to do.
You  also end up with a problem that astronomers had
in the 17th century which is that you get weird
distortions unless you use very specific lens shapes.
In the 1600s, two astronomers came up with two different lens shapes that helped to fix this problem.
Here's the one that Christiaan Huygens came up with.
and here's the one that René Descartes came up with.
Yes, that René Descartes.
He did a lot of stuff.
And here are the eye-lens shapes for the trilobite, Crozonapsis and the trilobite Dalmanitina.
This is so dang cool, right?
These lens shapes allowed for objects to be in focus
when they were pretty close up or pretty far away
and also got rid of some of that lens distortion.
It took humans 300 million years
to catch up with trilobite evolution!
I just love it
And if you want to learn more about trilobites,
our first episode is up!
youtube.com/eons, where me, Blake and Callie will be taking you through the entire history of life on Earth!
It's going to be fun! Join us there.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.